technology has been a big part of your
life then it's helped you a lot it's had
its benefits for sure yeah my I would
say my mother yes we talked about before
in case anyone didn't see that episode
you should did you have a fascinating
childhood yeah I came from to that my
parents are both deaf right
they were huge advantages and huge
disadvantages sneaking out of the house
was like incredibly easy in my house but
also it was difficult if I needed to
contact my mom I couldn't do it I
couldn't contact my mom if she was gone
like if she wanted to come if she was
out of the house I couldn't call her I
couldn't text her now with texting and
and with FaceTime I can talk to her in
real time and it's really an important
it's been a huge benefit to our lives
like now if she wants to make me feel
guilty we don't have to set an
appointment she can just straight send
me a bit mochi and it'll make me feel
like [ __ ] like almost the deal I
actually brought one this is this one
your mom sent you look at like the worst
episode of Sesame Street and yeah I know
I know also why does she look like Yoko
Ono Chang
[Laughter]
well it sounds fascinating problematic
with Moshe kasher airs Tuesdays at 10:00
on Comedy Central I'm in favor of
anything where there's less sort of
vitriol and people are listening to each
other yeah the thing is when we stop
agreeing with each other that's when we
stop talking and I think that's when we
have to start talking base yeah well
this is the perfect time for me to cut
you off
you